[Music]
a hair divides what is true from what is
false
the world is full of magical things
patiently waiting for our senses to grow
sharper
[Music]
do not grieve over the past for it is
done do not be troubled about the future
for it has yet to come live in the
present and make it so beautiful that it
will be worth remembering
the rose and the thorn like sorrow and
gladness are linked together
[Music]
live in the moment for it is the only
time that truly belongs to you
do not be afraid to lose someone who is
not afraid to lose you
[Music]
the world is a playground and life is a
fleeting moment of joy
the universe is a vast puzzle seek the
pieces of wisdom to complete it
[Music]
don't be a slave to appearances seek the
reality behind them
life's Caravan moves swiftly sees the
moments of Happiness as they pass
learn from Nature's lessons the Rose's
Beauty lasts but a moment yet it blooms
with all its might
[Music]
the road of life is filled with thorns
and flowers Embrace both with equanimity
desire and attachment are chains that
bind seek Freedom through detachment
time is a river that carries away all we
possess hold on to moments not things
[Music]
seek knowledge as you would seek hidden
treasure it enriches the soul
[Music]
the sun sets and rises again Embrace
life cycles with Grace
[Music]
love is the fire that warms our hearts
but wisdom is the compass that guides us
[Music]
beauty is transient like the morning dew
seek The beauty within for it is eternal
[Music]
the heart is a garden tend to it with
love and it will Bloom with joy
The Book of Life is written with Deeds
not words
fear not the unknown embrace it as an
opportunity for growth
life's tapestry is woven with threads of
joy and sorrow appreciate both for they
create its intricate Beauty
[Music]
is it the stars and Ponder the vastness
of the cosmos then realize that the
Universe exists within you
seek truth in simplicity the most
profound wisdom often lies in the
simplest truths
[Music]
the mirror reflects your face but your
heart reflects your soul
[Music]
in Silence the mysteries of Life unfold
listen to The Whispers of your heart
adversity is a teacher it reveals your
strength and shapes your character
[Music]
path of Enlightenment is not a
destination but a continuous exploration
of the self
[Music]
wisdom is a lantern that illuminates the
darkness of ignorance
love is the bridge that connects Hearts
transcending time and space
regret is a visitor from the past that
it teach then did it farewell
embrace the ebb and flow of life's Tides
they carry lessons and opportunities
[Music]
befriend time for it unveils the truths
that lie hidden in the folds of
experience
[Music]
the sun's Journey teaches that even the
brightest days must yield tonight
[Music]
the path of understanding is paved with
questions Embrace curiosity as a guide
[Music]
like a river time flows one way
make the most of its currents and Shores
foreign
of your thoughts the mind is a refuge of
peace
[Music]
each step you take is a footprint in the
sands of time tread lightly and with
intention
every sunset is a promise of a new dawn
find Hope in the cycles of nature
to find your way follow the north star
of your aspirations
[Music]
do not let the noise of the world drown
the whisper of your soul
the wind carries Tales of distant lands
let it be the messenger of your dreams
[Music]
love is the essence that unites all
souls seek it in every corner of
existence
the river of time erodes the shores of
the past build foundations in the
present
like a candle's flame life is fragile
and fleeting let it illuminate the
darkness
[Music]
echo of your actions reverberates
Through Time make it resonate with
kindness
[Music]
love is a river that nourishes the roots
of your soul let it flow freely
do not fear the storms of life they
cleanse and renew the spirit
foreign
the past is a chapter written let it
teach but do not rewrite it
[Music]
love is a universal language that
transcends borders speak it fluently
[Music]
in The Labyrinth of existence your
choices are the threads of Destiny
[Music]
seek Stillness within the chaos it is
there that Clarity emerges
The Whispers of the wind carry the
secrets of the universe listen closely
in the theater of Life the choices you
make are the scripts you enact
[Music]
embrace the rain as well as the sunshine
both nurture growth
you can't seduce a man who has a woman
he loves
[Music]
do not believe the one who speaks
beautifully there was always a game in
his words believe the one who silently
does beautiful things
if you want respect you must also give
it to others recognizing the inherent
worth in every individual
a wise person never shares three things
with anyone his innermost fears his
regrets and his excuses for arriving
late
[Music]
the universe is a book of mysteries open
its pages with curiosity
the mirror of self-reflection reveals
the truth within gaze into it with
honesty
to find peace release the burden of
regrets and worries they are anchors
that weigh down the spirit
[Music]